Wait…did Otto Hightower really
just say that? And why would
he even suggest such a thing? Here's
the creepiest thing that's happened in
House of the Dragon so far. Beware:
spoilers for episode 3, just ahead!
It is known that House of the Dragon and Game of
Thrones have been partly inspired by real-life
historical events, while at the same time being
filled to the brim with creepy and awkward
situations. We suppose that is to be expected,
though, since real-life history has its fair
share of bad decisions. As reported by BBC, author
George R.R. Martin drew heavily from the real-life
14th-century conflict known as the "Hundred
Years' War" in the crafting of his novels.
Knowing that series creator Martin is a history
buff, and with fans expecting a certain amount
of scheming, viewers are probably watching the
actions of characters very closely. Although
there are no obvious Littlefinger or Tywin
Lannister types yet, certain actions from
Otto Hightower are starting to raise some red
flags. So far, we have seen Otto manipulate his
own young daughter into marrying King Viserys,
as well as antagonize Daemon Targaryen. But it
seems as if Otto's recent suggestion in Episode
3 may be the creepiest power grab of all time.
Episode 3 of House of the Dragon is primarily
focused on lines of succession. Previously,
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen is named heir to
the Seven Kingdoms by her father, King Viserys,
after the death of his newborn son and wife.
Although there has never been a queen in the
history of Westeros, Viserys is determined
that he made the right choice. Unfortunately,
many of his subjects and advisors
openly question his decision.
This issue of succession is compounded
even more when Viserys marries Alicent,
and she gives birth to a male heir. Named Aegon,
which apparently is an exceptionally popular name
among the Targaryens, the child is assumed
by the realm to be the eventual new heir,
so much so that other royal houses make
marriage proposals aimed at Rhaenyra. The
most insufferable proposal fans have seen
thus far has been that of Jason Lannister,
who has all of the trademark arrogance
of others of the same last name.
"Thank you for the wine."
Though Rhaenyra rebuffs Jason's advances,
and even fights with her father over his
attempts to find her a suitable match, she
declares that she doesn't want to marry,
and just wants to be queen. King Viserys then
proclaims that as royalty, they are honor-bound to
tradition and that they must marry to strengthen
bloodlines and the lines of succession. He then
adds that he will not force her hand and that
she can marry whomever she chooses. However,
that isn't an idea Otto Hightower thinks is good,
and he has an entirely different suggestion.
Otto suggests that Viserys
betroth Rhaenyra to Aegon,
which should immediately get viewers to recoil
in disgust as Otto honestly considers having
a half-sister and brother marry each other.
This isn't unheard of in Targaryen history,
as they have a reputation for marrying family
members for the so-called preservation of a "pure
bloodline." This has been previously mentioned
by Cersei and Jamie Lannister in Game of Thrones,
who justify their own relationship by referencing
the Targaryen tradition of marrying siblings.
Considering the political
maneuvering of Otto Hightower,
this makes sense as he wants to strengthen his
own grandson's claim on the Iron Throne. Since
there is some debate as to who the heir
will be, by marrying the two siblings,
there would be one unified claim. This
isn't without historical precedent,
as real-life royal marriage between blood
relatives was relatively common up until the
onset of World War I. This practice, perceived as
keeping royal blood pure, often resulted in rare
genetic diseases and physical abnormalities
– and was also, of course, insanely gross.
As previously mentioned, the Targaryens do have a
habit of marrying blood relatives, and the realm
often suffers for it. Whatever his reasons, Otto
should not be absolved for making the suggestion;
the thought of it is stomach churning. Although
he seems to have his sights on asserting control
of the Iron Throne, he can also relish in his
newly acquired award for "creepiest advice ever."